le groupe d'opposition de gauche mord
pas dynamique et solidaire et ces deux
élus municipaux lancent leur campagne
pour les élections de 2020 avec une
liste du même nom quatre grands axes de
travail transition écologique démocratie
pluralisme et justice sociale
pas d'étiquette un assemblement avant
tout citoyen et participatif tête de
liste l'ingénieur et entrepreneurs
ismaila vannes nous avons créé ce groupe
en 2014
avec déjà l'intitulé citoyens alors ce
n'est pas un effet de mode en tout cas
en ce qui nous concerne nous tout
simplement l'évolution naturelle d'un
mouvement qui a été engagé il y à déjà 5
ans le programme est en cours de
réalisation la liste présentera son
projet complet lors de ses traditionnels
voeux avant d'entamer une tournée des
quartiers avec des réunions thématiques
en février à maurepas on est moins de
familles là on est 19600 donc on peut
que créer une bonne dynamique
donc il ya le centre commercial qu'il
faut redynamiser
il ya plein de choses il ya plein de
challenge et ça ça me convient beaucoup
vouloir que je redonner la parole aux
citoyens et puis faire en sorte qu'une
municipalité fonctionne de façon plus
démocratique
c'est toujours un bon objectif après
faut le tenir c'est pas facile
en 2014 la liste avait remporté 13,33 %
des voix au second tour
en refusant de s'allier à celle menée
par michel chappe à la ville avait
basculé à droite après 25 ans de
majorité divers gauche